こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
久しぶりに学校
中学校を思い出しますね。
僕が中学校の時、
中二まではめちゃくちゃ頭が悪くて
100点中16点とかの成績だったんですけども、
そこから、なんか塾とかに通って覚醒して、
中二の終わり位から、
ずっとちょっと、学年トップぐらいに、ずっといたっていう
思い出があります。
今回は皆さんに「スタディサプリ」というものを
ご紹介したいと思います。
スタディサプリは、
タブレットやパソコンなどで勉強出来る
オンライン学習サービスのことで、
小学生・中学生・高校生を対象とした、サービスです。
有名なプロ講師の授業動画や、
そのほかの様々な学習のコンテンツを
タブレットやパソコンなどで気軽に勉強できる
スタイルとなっております。
ところで皆さん…
YouTuber。
皆、バカっぽく見えませんか？
なんで今回は、
ちょっとYouTuber、本当にバカなのかを
テストとかで一回確かめてみようと思います。
で、多分僕の予想だと
YouTuberはみんなバカだと思うんで、
そのバカなYouTuber達が、
スタディサプリを使って、
本当にその学力が上がるかどうかっていうのを
今回ちょっと検証してみようと思います。
では行こう。
はい、という訳で今から
おバカなYouTuberを何人か呼んだので、
ちょっと実際に教室の方に入ってもらおうと思います。
そらちぃ) へ？
入りなさい。
そらちぃ) はいどうも。アバンティーズのそらちぃと
ツリメ) ツリメです。
はい、ありがとうございます！
アバン) えへへwありがとうございます？
とりあえず、座ってください。
そ) いんすか、ここで
いいよ
カンタ) えーはいどうもー
ボンド) 水溜りボンドですお願いします
はい、ありがとうございます
ぽむぽむゆうり) ぽむぽむゆうりです
ますこゆみ) ますこゆみです
日向結衣) 日向結衣です
つんたろう) つんたろうです
ちょこばなな) ちょこばななです
どうぞ！
TAKASHI) 「TAKASHI'sTV!!!」のTAKASHIです
K) 「TAKASHI'sTV!!!」のKです
ぎこちゃん) 「TAKASHI'sTV!!!」の...
TA) いや違うでしょw
ぎ) じゃないぎこちゃんです
皆) おーーー
さとちん) はいども！さとちんです
Masuo) はい、Masuoで～す
Dante) はいMasuoでぇす
Ma) 違ぇよ
皆) HAHAHAHAww
Ma) 違ぇよ！
とりあえず席の方に、
着いていただいて。
もう一席、一応余ってるんですけども...
最後の一人はこの方です、どうぞ！
ガチャンx1
ガチャンx2
ガチャンx3
えー最後の一人はトミックさんということでー
拍手(音効)
はいという訳で今回皆さんにお集まり頂いたのは、
僕ぁ思うんですよ。
YouTuberはバカなんじゃねぇかと。
皆) HAHAHA
そ) どんな偏見だよ
YouTuberの学力を計ろうと思いまして。
ちょっと抜き打ちでテストをしていきたいと、思います。
えと自身ある人はいると思うんですよ。
早稲田卒の、
あとバカな人も。
いるかもしれません。
視聴者の皆さんも気になるところだと思うので
実際に
みなさんに問題を解いていただいて
本当に頭がよいのかどうなのか
まずちょっと調べていこうと思います
よろしくお願いします
一同）よろしくお願いします
では配る！
一同）うあーー
制限時間は１０分
問題数が２０問になります
Ma)この感じ約１０年ぶりぐらい
一同）ｗｗｗｗｗ
ではカンニング禁止で
では
テスト開始
終了〜。お疲れさまでした。
ちょっと採点してくるんで、皆さんしばしお待ちを
おお
一同）ｗｗｗｗｗ
お待たせしました。
一同）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
まずは順位の方から行きます。
一同）うあーーヤバイヤバイ
2位から順番に
一同）えーー
発表します。
2位、2人います。
100点中50点
一同）すげー
一同）２位で５０点ｗｗ
カンタとチョコバナナさん
一同）おーー
4位、45点
一同）おー
トミー
一同）おっ
5位、40点
TAKASHI'sTV!!!のTAKASHI
一同）おー
一同）えっ
続いて６位
Kさん
一同）えーいがい
７位
３０点
ぽむぽむゆうり
一同）おー
では、８位
３人います
ツリメ
つんたろう
日向結衣
次のビリ以外の４位は全部おんなじです
11位
ぎこちゃん
トミック
ト）ウソ
さとちんさん
そらちぃ
Ma)オレは？
Ma)ダンテは？
ダ）オレまだ呼ばれてない
ダ）オレじゃない？
あ、ダンテ
ダンテ２０
あと2人残ってます。誰でしょうか
１位発表します
得点２位と１０点差で６０点
一同）おーー
（ドラムロール）
MasuoTV!!
ということで、ビリの１６位は
１５点ますこゆみ
回答をいろいろ丸付けしていたんですけど
珍回答が多かったです
というわけで、みんなでゆっくり見ていきましょう珍回答
わたしたちの食べ物のもとをたどっていくと、すべて（　　）にたどりつきます。
正解者ゼロ
正解は、わたしたちの食べ物のもとをたどっていくと、すべて（植物）にたどりつきます。
一同）うあーーー
日向結衣
りんご！
そらちぃ
そ）オレかよ
プランクトン
ちょこばなな
プランワトン
目の問題です
Masuoさん
さとちんさん
おうかくまく
植物はどこから水を吸い上げますか？という問題
ぎこちゃんさんの答え
答え正解です
ますこゆみ
どこから水を吸い上げますか？
土ｗ
江戸時代を作った人物を答えなさい
ぽむぽむゆうり
日向結衣こちら
織田長信
現在世界にはおおよそどれくらいの国がありますか
これ正解者２人だけです
ちょこばななさんとトミーだけ
正解はこちら
約１９５カ国
ビリのかたの回答
こちら
つんたろうさん
琵琶湖は（　　）の全面積の約６分に１を占めます
滋賀県
ぎこちゃんさん
ぎ）ヤバイ
琵琶湖は日本の全面積の約６分の１を占めます
世界貿易機関の略称....
World Trade Organization
まずはダンテから
世界貿易機関の略称は...
GPS
もう一人TAKASHIさん
世界貿易機関の略称こちら
WBC
ツリメ
WBK
何の略なのこれは？
ツ）Wは世界
ツ）Bは貿易（ローマ字）
ツ）Kは機関（ローマ字）
次の漢文を書き下し文に直しなさい
国破れて山皮在り
さとちんさん
ふざけてますねこれは
こっぱさんが
円に対する接線は接点を通る直径と（　　）になる
さとちんさんの答え
正解ですこちら
垂直
円に対する
接線だから接している線
こう
たとえばココらへん
ココを通る直線をかけば...
一同）垂直じゃないｗｗ
あれ？
ココが接点ですよね
これが
垂直です
そういうことです
円柱を書きなさいという問題です
トミー
ト）えっオレちゃんと書きましたよ
こちら
左手で書いたんですよ
いいじゃないですか
次の（　　）にあてはまる不等号を書きなさい。
これはぽむぽむゆうりがちょっと
珍回答でした
こちら
≒（ニアリーイコール）
次の単語を英語にしなさい
土曜日
日向結衣
suterbay?
トミー
解読不可
ト）かけないんすよ
次の英文を日本語に直しなさい
ダンテ
Shall I take your Jkcket?
ダンテの訳はこちらです
という感じでした
おつかれさまです
みなさんには居残り勉強をしてもらいたいと思います
今回こちらのスタディサプリの動画があるので
これでちょっと勉強して復習して
間違いをしっかり理解して
正しい答えが言えるように勉強しましょう
スタディアプリ）ロウソクの火が消えました
Ma）これで見れるらしい
トミック）なるほどねすげえなー
ダ）これ見てやれば
ぽ）わかりやすいよね
はいみなさん動画どうだったでしょうか
トミック）頭良くなるね勉強すると
トミック）考える力がつくもんね
そ）動画が短いから見やすい
そう短いから１回の動画が
というわけで
つぎは全員で１６人連続正解しないと帰れませんゲームをします
一同）えーーー
はい、というわけでYouTuber学力テストいかがだったでしょうか？
すごいいろんな珍回答が出たんですけども
今回使ったスタディサプリ
中学生版では３年間の内容を網羅しています
部活とかの両立が可能で
テストやニガテの克服もできます
小学講座では、小学４生～小学６年生の授業をすべて網羅しています
スマホやタブレット、パソコンでいつでも勉強できるので
勉強習慣のない子供でも
習慣にすることができます
このスタディサプリなんと
小学講座・中学講座両方使えて月９８０円で使い放題ととてもお安い価格になっております
みなさんよかったらぜひ使って見てください
それではスタディアプリで勉強したＹｏｕＴｕｂｅｒたち
学力はどうなっているのでしょうか
後半にご期待ください